Many softbots are little better than balloon animals --
they are flexible and move by inflating in one direction.
Now researchers are looking into creating
complex softbots -- that can reversibly change shape.
They based their approach on cephalopods
like octopuses and cuttlefish.
These animals not only change the color of their skin,
but also its shape and texture.
They are able to raise “papillae” by activating muscles
that encircle areas of skin and muscle.
The muscles within the circle dictate
the shape of the raised area.
Researches emulated this in silicone inflatable skins
using a mesh of fiber embedded in the layers.
The elastomer skin stretches when inflated with air
and the embedded mesh provides reinforcement.
Much like a string wrapped around a balloon
will change its shape, the mesh restricts
stretching in certain areas,
controlling the overall 3D shape.
They went even further and made the rings
different sizes, shapes, and arrangements
building camouflaged rocks.
And a succulent plant.
They even created one that glows in the dark!
These are complex shapes,
but they are the only ones these skins can make.
But this is only the beginning of
camouflaging robot skins.
To come are more complex textures
and more selective activation of shapes and colors.
Someday these skins or camouflaged robots
may be used for hiding observation devices in the field
and disguising machines in natural spaces.